the Trump organization is rejecting a
new claim of profiteering during former
president Trump's time in the office the
house oversight committee says Trump
owned hotels charged excessive rates
sometimes more than one thousand dollars
a night for a room for Secret Service
Personnel protecting the Trump family
Scott McFarland is on Capitol Hill with
more on this story so good morning to
you Scott the question I have is how
much is excessive
now according to the records newly
released by Congress Gail the Trump
hotels and properties charge the Secret
Service as much as five times the
Government rate for some accommodations
over the course of four years that
amounted to more than 1.4 million
dollars in tax money that went to the
Trump organization in one case the
Secret Service was charged more than
eleven hundred dollars for a room at the
Trump International Hotel here in
Washington for agents protecting Trump's
son Eric in March 2017. that's well
above the 242 dollars allowed under the
Government rate committee documents also
reference agent visits to Trump's
Bedminster Golf Club in Mar-A-Lago while
citing a statement from Eric Trump in
2019 that the Secret Service effectively
stays at Trump properties for free and
saves the government money
the committee says there may also be
other expenses it hasn't seen yet
they've asked the Secret Service for a
complete list of taxpayer-funded
expenses at Trump properties and the
agency tells CBS News it will respond to
the panel in a statement to CBS News
Eric Trump stands by his claim that the
arrangement was for at Cost discounted
and free stays and says the
organizations would have made more money
by selling services to full paying
guests Nate
Scott thank you